welcome back to pennsylvania well this
didn't take long within hours of ricky
gervais's hilarious new netflix special
being released the council culture mob
is trying to finish him off claiming
that his jokes about the trans community
are hurtful and damaging
i love the the new whip i know they're
new i mean they're great aren't they you
know the new ones we've been seeing
lately there were the ones with beards
and they're as good as
they're as good as gold i love them
no it's the old fashioned way and now
the old fashioned they go oh they want
to use our toilets why shouldn't they
use your toilets for ladies
they are ladies look at their pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
her penis
joining me now is a filmmaker writer and
actor john waters and trans comedian
dahlia bell so welcome uh to both of you
darling let me start with you
um
i watched the whole ricky gervais
netflix special
and it was outrageous
uh it was very funny
it was controversial
it was laugh out loud and shocking but
ultimately it was comedy
what do you think
is that
is that a question or just your opinion
it's my verdict on the thing i just
wondered whether a have you seen the
whole thing or are you reacting just to
the clips that have gone around twitter
today
yeah so i haven't um gotten a chance to
see the full thing yet unfortunately
only the clips uh which just aren't
funny
it's it's more a matter of boredom for
me than anything else though
right i mean
let me ask you though
do you find any jokes about the trans
community funny
or do you believe that they should
absolutely i mean
i've been trying to struggle
if i was to tell a trans joke now would
you laugh if it was funny
if it was well written and it was funny
then absolutely
you see this is my problem uh john
because i i don't think
that that is true because whenever i've
tried to
have fun with the trans community about
any of these issues all hell braces i
had a trans activist on last week trying
to talk about some of these issues and
was
screamed down and abuse held at me and
so on
what do you feel about this i mean it's
ricky gervais dave chappelle these guys
doing this stuff on netflix
are they crossing a line or is there not
a line for comedians should they be
allowed to
effectively mock any community
john can you hear me yes maybe
that was for john actually john can you
hear me
me yes yes john that was aimed at you
is there a line is there a line that
comedian shouldn't cross when it comes
to the trans community or should they be
like any other community just should
take their comedic medicine
yeah
well here's how i get i get it you know
it's a straight guy making trans jokes
and trans people i get why they're angry
they get murdered you know there's
nowhere for them to go to the bathroom
when they're out but i think i can make
jokes about i have in my new book a dog
that believes he is trapped in the body
of a cat and starts living the life of
surprise with a z and the other pets
accept them except for his facelift that
because
she's had a facelift that makes her look
kind of the winds tunnel look like joan
crawford so yes i think you can but
maybe if it's a straight guy ask eddie
lizard what he thinks
right eddie yeah i mean eddie would
probably say he could laugh i want to
play another clip uh to you if i can
dahlia this is also from the ricky
gervais netflix special it's about why
he feels he should tell trans jokes
i talk about aids famine cancer the
holocaust rape pedophilia but no the one
thing you mustn't joke about is identity
problems the one thing you should never
joke about is the trans issue right they
just want to be treated equally i agree
that's why i include them
now you are a trans comedian
right is he right is he right to say if
you're going to be genuinely inclusive
dahlia then you should include everyone
and everything
as long as you're original and creative
with it then sure why not
yeah i mean that that to me is the
bottom line you know when i when i watch
the whole special and i know how gervais
works a lot of the humor is poking fun
at people and the way they go about
having these debates
it's not designed to be malicious he
says in the in the special i you know he
fully supports trans rights i've seen
trans comedians uh coming up on twitter
today saying he's always been very
supportive i don't think he's got a
transphobic bone in his body and yet
within hours of this special being
released he's being bombarded with abuse
and people trying to cancel him for
being transphobic and don't they have
every right to be offended and say they
don't like a joke
well they have they do they don't have
any right to tell people i don't like
and if they don't like it then i rewrite
the joke who's been canceled well no no
like give me an example of one comic
that's actually i will give you an exact
example of somebody literally sexually
assaulted women
i don't i'm not defending that here's
what i would say to you
dave chappelle as you know was nearly
cancelled from netflix by an internal
uprising by now oh yeah yeah
60 million dollars i feel so bad it
wasn't successful but you did yeah but
you do know there are attempts to cancel
people like chappelle like ricky gervais
i just wonder whether you as a trans
community people are saying they don't
like things it doesn't matter
but there's a difference between saying
you don't find something funny or even
that you find the defensive of course
you can do that but you shouldn't have
to then cancel people or demand they
lose their jobs that to me is a line
where free speech gets trashed
except that we also have three things to
say that we don't think someone should
have a job
all right john come in there
uh so i i think it's it's much easier
like uh i i don't do a lot of black
jokes i'm not black i don't do a lot of
jewish jokes i'm not jewish it really
helps if you are the minority that's
making the joke about minority but i do
do believe that everything is fair and
and comedy is a cliff you walk in when
when i was young the sensors were
against any kind of nudity and the
sensors today on the other side come in
if you make a movie and someone's nude
they have an intimacy coach where you
have to put a fake vagina over the
vagina if anybody's going to have lunch
downtown because then you're not
touching the real thing so it is
confusing
[Laughter]
darling last word to you because i do
think i do want to have respect for the
trans community i don't want to expose
the trans community to any bigotry or
hatred but i do think that part of the
way through all this is for everyone to
perhaps have a same sense of humor that
perhaps you do about it actually
perhaps
i think everyone's entitled to approach
it as they see fit
well let's leave it there because i
happen to agree with you
john
would you agree with that
are there any trans are there any trans
comedians i'm trying to think of i know
a lot of gay comedians you know that's
what i don't get we all used to be in
this together gay drag queens trans
everybody all together now we're
fighting with each other i think we
should all just scare straight people i
try to well if i'm ever at an office
party and i see a straight guy like
sucking down a oyster i tell them that's
what it's like you know just to make
people nervous i think gays trans i mean
we should just gather together and make
people nervous i like that there's
actually a funny bit in gervais's
special where he talks about being a
minority because he's a white
middle-aged
multi-millionaire and it's quite it's a
funny sketch anyway listen thank you
both very much to john walders to daniel
bell it's a good debate and hopefully we
can keep laughing that's the most
important thing